[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport à
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire course ce
dimanche 31 mars 7e la 7e run and bike
de bioko où étaient organisées dans les
étangs de la millière plus de 130
participants se sont inscrits cette
année reportage à un martiaux une nuit
était organisée ce samedi 30 mar six
associations ont pu montrer des figures
à travers un spectacle de trois heures
trente
plus d'informations ce magazine
équitation aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur un jeune ville provient
adrien coller cet athlète handisport de
24 ans est devenu en l'espace de
quelques mois l'un des meilleurs
cavaliers de la région grâce à son lien
avec son cheval l'actualité sportive de
la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence ce magazine par une course
la 7e édition de la run and bike de
guyancourt était organisée ce dimanche
matin autour de l'étang de la minière au
total plus d'une soixantaine d'équipés à
participer au départ du 15 km sur des
chemins forestiers des images de nicolas
landry à remontage de et xavier jaglin
dimanche matin étant de la minière plus
de 130 personnes se sont inscrites au
départ de la septième run and bike de
bus en cours
une course qui mêle cyclisme et course à
pied en duo quelques minutes avant le
départ les participants étaient pleins
d'enthousiasmé fond et puis ralentir sur
la fin parce que je crois qu'à une côte
pour finir donc ça reste un peu
compliqué donc on va partir très
rapidement dès le départ on va continuer
très rapidement toulon on devrait pas
être trop mal je pense qu'en croisés
notamment au programme de cette course
15 km avec deux montées sur des chemins
forestiers en terre ou en bitume pour
terminer la course il faut donc coopérer
sur le parcours la bonne stratégie c'est
de changer assez souvent comme ça le
coureur à pied fait un espèce de
fractionner il est le plus souvent à
pleine vitesse
et quand ils fatiguent il prend le vélo
pour se reposer puisque le vélo à quand
on est sur le vélo on est beaucoup moins
sollicité physiquement la course a
finalement été remporté par maxime st
martin et antoine la snrt du triathlon
club saint quentin en yvelines en 48
minutes et 4 secondes duo a devancé de
près de 4 minutes ses adversaires ouais
c'était dur l aco s'appliquer les gens
allaient à lakota l'a fait mal france du
coup on en a su réguler antoine il
commis les meilleurs comme en vélo il a
fait la côte à vélo et les parties
devant et après il m'a passé le relais
et on a on a bien joué là dessus du côté
des mécontents rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une huitième édition
autour des étangs de la minière il y
avait également du football ce week-end
dans le championnat de d1 de district
maurepas s'est imposé 3 1 à domicile
face au fc mantois lui en courant porte
le derby contre plaisir sur la plus
petite des marges 1 0
le chesnay s'incline 2 1 face à marly le
roi hardricourt s'en va remporter une
précieuse victoire sur le terrain de
kariya grésillons tout comme mouiller
sur le terrain de gargenville enfin
match nul entre montesson et
sartrouville
un partout au classement où il garde la
tête devant à marly le roi on continue
par le championnat de régionale 3 trap a
connu la première défaite de sa saison
ce week end les trappistes se sont
inclinés 1 à 0 face à epinay ce dimanche
à l'extérieur une défaite qui pourrait
être lourde de conséquences à la fin de
la saison sera pointe à la troisième
place du classement avec deux points de
retard sur boulogne billancourt
après le football on passe au rugby
c'est cheuvreux qui remporte le derby du
week-end face au sky les chevrotins se
sont imposés sur le terrain de saint
quentinois sur le score de 42 à 12
une victoire qui permet à l'équipe du
sud des yvelines de s'emparer de la
troisième place avec 54 points
le sky rugby de son côté reste à la
septième place du classement avec un
bilan de 5 victoires 1 nuls et 11
défaites
on ouvre maintenant une page pentathlon
moderne sport olympique depuis 1912 qui
regroupe cinq disciplines l'escrimé la
natation l'équitation le tir au pistolet
la course à pied à versailles un
tunisien vise les jo de 2024 son nom web
ciao chaouachi et nous recevons sur ce
plateau désolé pour le titre aux notions
bonsoir alors comment vous est venue
cette passion départ je me suis inscrit
dans un club de pentathlon en club mais
munisport pas tellement une course à
pied pour faire de la course et une la
natation et ils m'ont fait découvrir le
tir au pistolet et ainsi de suite on se
retrouve avec une épée à la main et une
cravache si on devient pâte athlètes
alors c'est une passion qui vous est
arrivé très tard finalement on en fait
j'ai commencé le pentacle à la course à
pied tirer natation il ya trois ans les
scream ya un an et demi et l'équitation
ya six mois et pourquoi
pourquoi avoir démarré si tard alors on
a la balle à l'origine je suis un
basketteur se fait principalement du
basket et un peu de judo et
avec l'âge on nous dit que on devient
plus fatigués content qu'on a plus de
pathologies qu'il faut faire de la
natation donc j'ai commencé un petit peu
où ce sport là pour avoir une activité
d'activité physique
j'ai retrouvé l'esprit de compétition et
ainsi de suite et de fil en aiguille on
apprend que la tunisie n'a participé
qu'une seule fois aux jo en 1960 et on
se donne un objectif et ensuite on se
donne les moyens
alors comment vous entraîner justement
alors est ce que vous êtes soutenus par
la fédération tunisienne
là actuellement j'ai eu aucun soutien
puisque tout se fait enfin aucun soutien
financier puisque je suis déjà le seul
pentathlètes tunisien je vis en france
donc je m'inscris auprès des différents
clubs là je suis à versailles pour
faciliter puisque les dernières les
trois heures de transport par jour pour
aller faire du pentathlon à paris
c'était un peu difficile
là cette fois ci c'est plus facile car
j'ai tout à côté de chez moi et en même
temps j'apporte un projet avec deux
créations de club de pentathlon puisque
je suis en contact avec les différents
présidents de clubs ainsi que le service
des sports de la ville de versailles
pour apporter mais qu'aucun et mon
expertise méconnaissance et comment
adapter et profiter de la visibilité
puisque le gio de pentathlon se feront à
versailles parce que justement vous le
disiez léger ou s'offrant à versailles
mais vous vous entraînez sur différents
sites également pour l'instant vous
pouvez pas vous entraîner sur un seul et
unique site
or bien là sur versailles je fais la
natation au club de gym soit mont boron
soit sa théorie pour la piscine pour la
natation la course à pied à mont boron
au porge fontaine sont les stades sur
versailles il ya que les kits l'escrim
toujours à versailles le tir sportif
dans le très grand club de tir de
versailles tir national de versailles où
je profite de l'expertisé parce que
c'est plus qu'un club c'est aussi une
annexe de la fédération où il ya une
grande partie de formation fédérales et
l'équitation jeu délocalisé à houdan aux
écuries as de pique et quel est votre
point fort est votre point faible
j'imagine qu'ils y en a quelques-uns
l'escrinet à 5,5 discipline je le
rappelle alors les scream c'est un point
fort puisque j'ai une grande allonge
c'est un avantage d'être très grand
et on dit avant de l'entendre me dit
j'ai le sens de la touche
peut-être que j'ai pu récupérer des
compétences de sport d'opposition
j'avais fait auparavant judo mais aussi
au basket
puisqu'on même si c'est un sport
d'équipé on est quand même responsable
d'un seul joueur en natation
beaucoup de progrès puis j'ai fait deux
mètres des jeux distincts verdure ça
aide à peu près la moyenne des des
nageurs actuels qui sont des nageurs en
effet pas des tentatives pas des
retraites devait nageurs des nageurs et
en équitation là c'est encore très
récent
je viens de commencer les compétitions
d'équitation équitation pure et non pas
en taclant ce qu'ils font un galop s'ils
font un niveau très élevé car la
particularité en équitation pentathlon
sont des chevaux en tirent au hasard et
on a vingt minutes pour le découvrir
alors il ya des plus docile au plus
rebelle iliona qu'il faut entretenir la
lure d'autres je vais pas dire qu'il
suffit de tenir les rênes mais c'est
beaucoup plus facile
donc il faut un niveau ne serait ce que
pour la sécurité du cavalier comme du
cheval il nécessaire d'avoir un très bon
niveau au niveau de kavala donc pour
l'instant on ne disait pas de club de
pentathlon moderne à versailles
il en faut obligatoirement pour marquer
le coup également en vue des jo de 2024
c'est une grande opportunité que
versailles a en créant un club de
pentathlon
car déjà même dans les yvelines pas ou
très peu de club de pentathlon et versa
il avantage qu'elle a c'est que déjà
l'histoire de versailles il ya le fait
aussi que
rares sont les villes qui dispose de
toutes les infrastructures pour faire de
l'équitation et en plus les cinq clubs
danser chaque discipline ont un très bon
niveau de pédagogie de pédagogie
différenciée puisque même pas prenons un
exemple club de natation entraîne aussi
bien les nageurs que les triathlètes de
qui sont ils sont aptes j'ai pu le voir
avec l'expérience qu'ils sont aptes à
répondre à une demande à une spécificité
telle qu'elle peut être le patron et
ainsi de suite pour tous les autres
sports et c'est aussi l'occasion ne
serait ce que pour le pentathlon mais
aussi pour les cinq sports de profiter
de cette visibilité pour l'entrée déjà
augmenter la notoriété de versailles ou
sportives et et de profiter de cette
occasion j o à paris c'est déjà énorme
fait en plus à domicile c'est encore
plus que c'est encore mieux votre
objectif les jo de 2024 on l'a compris
ce serait une déception de ne pas y être
pour vous non parce que leurs
récompenses années déjà dans le fait de
supporter tous ces entraînements de
parce que c'est pas supporté dans le
sens où et combien d'heures par semaine
quand j'ai pas de compétition comme en
ce moment je suis entre 20 et 30 heures
donc
l'oreille à plein temps c'est quasi un
travail à plein temps donc c'est déjà la
récompense est déjà là le fait de tenir
c'est déjà une belle récompense la
médaille en réalité en plus elles sont
médaille d'or elle se mène pas encore
complètement bloquée en fin de compte
non c'est vrai qu'il a fait le pat
athlètes c'est quand même une
philosophie assez particulière dans le
sens où dans le sport je pars avec ses
origines militaires on n'est plus dans
l'accomplissement de soi le dépassement
de soi que dans le
la recherche d'un chrono pure et simple
ça sera forcément avec le maillot de la
tunisie si vous allez aux jo-2000 24 oui
avec la suivit la france a déjà la
concurrence est beaucoup plus importante
en france
ils sont une quinzaine moi je suis tout
ça j'ai d'autres difficultés d'autres
contraintes que le financement et les
aides pour les déplacements
c'est tout aussi dur mais avec le
maillot rouge et blanc merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite d'aller le plus loin possible
dans votre discipline et surtout d'aller
aux jo de 2024
merci beaucoup on continue par du
handball en nationale 2 féminine
montigny le bretonneux s'est incliné ce
samedi soir face à cergy lors de la 16e
journée du championnat
ce camp final 34 à 22 e défaite la
huitième de la saison qui fait
redescendre lésigny monteyne coachée par
denis cholet à la 7e place du classement
à 8 points du podium toujours handball
de cette fois ci à chez les garçons en
nationale 3 plaisir s'est incliné d'un
petit but face à saint mandé sur le
score de 21 à 20 à l'extérieur
une mauvaise opération au classement
plaisir est toujours sous la menace
d'une relégation en fin de saison
l'équipe de victor garrigues et ne
compte que trois petits points d'avancé
sur le premier non relégable
nous allons maintenant à parler de la
14e nuit des arts martiaux
l'événement organisé tous les deux ans à
vue en cours a permis à six associations
de la ville de promouvoir leur
discipline devant le grand public des
images de grégory canal est un montage
de jules grevy des sabres des kimonos
des figures spectaculaires l'on vous
n'êtes pas en asie mais à vue en cours
la nuit des arts martiaux organisé tous
les deux ans fêté ce samedi 30 mars à
14e édition au gymnase des droits de
l'homme
donc l'objectif c'est que nos
associations puissent montrer ce
qu'elles font ce qu'elles sont capables
de faire toute l'année et que le public
s'ébahissent de tout ça et puissent
éventuellement adhérer à une des
associations cette année six
associations se sont produits devant
plusieurs centaines de spectateurs
pendant trois heures et demie
c'est toujours un beau moment de partage
et des changes ont déjà entre nous voilà
ça crée une émulation de créer un
spectacle vivant et original
et puis ça permet aussi de rencontrer
les autres associations d'arts martiaux
pour créer un spectacle original les
associations travaillent pendant
plusieurs mois sur les techniques
propres à leur sport mais également sur
la mise en scène de leur démonstration
ce sont 1 prévu le thème du jeu vidéo
on a essayé de
de fusionner le judo avec un jeu de
combat avec toutou phase de tutorial
d'eau training de technique et de combat
à la fin avec avec un père et sa fille
qui jour je en parallèle du spectacle
visuel la soirée était également pour la
bonne cause l'intégralité des recettes
de l'événement étaient reversés à la
boutique alimentaire balises qui rendez
vous dans deux ans pour une nouvelle
édition
c'est ça on va maintenant rangé à les
kimonos pour parler basket dans ce
championnat de nationale 3 trappe s'est
imposé ce week-end face à l' alerte s p
de fondettes sur le score de 76 à 70
l'histoire qui leur permet de garder
leur deuxième place au classement pour
nous parler de ce match et de cette
saison nous recevrons sur ce plateau le
président jacques michel et le coach de
l'équipe senior aleksandar kirilov c'est
bien ce qu'ils font et bien prononcé et
l'intérieur de trappes mamadou diakité
bonsoir messieurs
alors on va tout d'abord revenir sur ce
match contre l' alerte sp2 foule est
comment s'est déroulée cette rencontre
soir deuxièmement games ne l'as partant
d'aussi grosses gouttes iphone du
sinistre got over the rainbow is more
difficult bottes il s'avère important
d'opter mort wind and his n'importe où
alors on m'avait dit vous allez faire la
traduction de couy donc c'était un match
difficile qu'a déjà d'une notre objectif
de monter en nationale 2 rebonds et
notre positionnement son classement
mentalement je pense que ça a été
c'était une déception à dire non pas par
l'équipe
mais bon malgré tout un match difficile
car ce parce qu'ils étaient quand même
assez motivés nous voulons nous battre
parce qu'on n'a pas une équipe de
tableau on n'a qu'à monsieur on vous
dira jacques michel et comment vous
l'avez aperçu ce match oui je crois que
les qualités qui vont ils doivent 76 à
70 ans
le rappelle absolument les qualités dont
on a fait preuve en la matière s'était
d'abord cette capacité de revenir
d'accepter la difficulté d'y faire face
est de trouver des solutions parce que
d'autres le ce match a très bien débuté
dans le premier quart temps parfait 10
points d'avancé tranquillement et puis
la deux le deuxième quart temps a été
catastrophique
et là on aurait pu penser que que la
deuxième mi temps allait suivre
non pas du tout nos joueurs ont su se
reprendre en chef faire bloc et puis et
bien trouver des solutions pour revenir
et pour s'imposer en quatrième
quart-temps mode vous pensé la même
chose vous vous étiez plus fort vraiment
que cette équipe où on est et on était
plus fort que maintenant après je pense
était son d'état d'esprit comme il l'a
expliqué première mi temps tu sais très
bien passé après en deuxième je sais pas
trop ce qui s'est passé un petit
relâchement peut-être mais on a su
rebondir vers ce à quoi une victoire
logique
alors encore une fois l'attaqué très
bien fonctionné il faut le dire je
rappelle que vous êtes la deuxième
meilleure attaque du championnat
seulement neuf points de la première
attaque
comment vous le percevez vous sur le
terrain je perçois c'est juste que je
fais du travail que con mes
entraînements tous les entraînements
qu'on fait et c'est pas prêt oui c'est
vrai que bon on a quand même pas mal de
qualités aussi individuelle danse à 15
ans dans l'équipe et je pense aussi à un
gros avantage là dedans quand on a
vraiment des joueurs peuvent scorer à
toutes les positions
est ce que vous sentez que l'équipe est
forte offensivement coach pièce je pense
comme ça at il ajouté
vermouth offensif team promet même il
est auprès des familles dont 10,6
willuth exact révolte du team quiz pour
5 classifie qui s'autoproduit exactement
ça c'est que super forte offensivement
après le cifad et ben ça a été la
défense parce qu'on pense un peu trop à
l'attaqué et la défense
les présidents comment vous l'expliquez
moi je voi m défensif que l'attak
oui je crois bien je crois que la
défense nécessite une communication
d'une très grande précision et qui est
très très immédiate
or nous avons nous avons un groupe ii
avec de multiples nationalités et pour
bien se comprendre et bien il faut qu'il
fasse référence à leurs réflexes plus
qu'à la parole et ça ça reste ça assez
resté durant cette saison un certain
handicap qui fait que à mon avis ça met
du temps à se mettre en place
oui tout à fait c'est fait alors durant
les premiers matches tout marchait très
bien le groupe s'était immédiatement
constituée on y avait veillé parce qu'on
savait que c'était notre faiblesse des
années précédentes
bompard fait même en défense les mêmes
dans ce cas là notre défense n'était pas
la hauteur de l'attaqué
et maintenant et bien en fait je crois
qu'il faut du temps d'abord notre coach
qui a fait l'effort de deux d'apprendre
le français il n'est pas encore au top
de ce point de vue là mais c'est que ce
sont des choses qui qu'il aura
l'occasion de parfaire l'année prochaine
peut absolument absolument prochaine
saison voilà et l'ensemble des joueurs
également et en avait qui parle qui
parlent anglais d'autres français dos et
puis aussi les cultures et les cultures
des cultures américaines
sur africaine notre culture également où
il faut que tout ça fasse un avenir à
tous morts et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est d'une complexité
au delà d'une stratégie sur un tableau
alors vous êtes donc deuxièmes du
championnat après cette victoire avec un
bilan de 14 victoires et 6 défaites
est-ce que vous aurez pu faire mieux oui
on peut toujours faire mieux c est à
trois points du premier poitiers c'est
ça dont on peut toujours faire mieux
après vous voilà les masques on a perdu
ça s'est joué sur des petits détails
il faudra maintenant bon comme on dit on
apprend toujours des défaites
donc voilà un bon coup de main à bosser
et puis les approuver deux prochains
matches qui restent
essai de parfaire leurs erreurs et puis
après d'ailleurs sa prochaine et
qu'est-ce qui a manqué finalement cette
saison à trappes je disais vous avez
perdu six matches c'est trop pour
prétendre à la montée
right thing we make l'os est important
d'une race voir will use rien décider
pour les autres
wii play football club russe de tours de
guet me trouveras ton départ willuth de
game devons système heureusement de ses
meneurs de la fin expliqué que donc il
ya 3 3 3 défaites qu'on avait à
l'extérieur dont surtout une contre une
équipe de l'intérieur de terminer le
championnat pendant les années du perdre
et donc ça ça va quand même beaucoup je
pense aussi dans mon temps
d'un mental de l'équipe et
et puis après une 2e aussi ça marche que
moi j'ai pas pu jouer que j'étais blessé
mais qu'on n'aurait pas dit pas non plus
aussi en déplacement et je pense que
c'est surtout ces deux masses là qui ont
fait que en sortent grâce au classement
la question président l'année prochaine
l'objectif ce sera la montée vous voulez
dormant sur nous et antérieures vous
échoué de si peu cette saison vous avez
dit que vous avez dit qu'on espérait la
montée dès cette saison
c'est pas tout à fait le cas cependant
oui bien sûr que comme disait ma roue
tout de suite on tire à chaque fois les
enseignements de nos faiblesses de nos
erreurs et bien là c'est là on les
reproduira pas ça me paraît clair
et puis je pense qu'on aura l'année
prochaine une grosse très grosse équipe
menacée
voilà bien un catho comment je peux pas
vous en dire plus encore c'est trop tôt
mais c'est encore trop tôt
mais oui je pense que l'on jouera très
très clairement la montée
et puis surtout je pense qu'on a
continué à la constitution de ce groupe
la constitution également de ce groupe
n'ont pas simplement du point de vue
superficiel mais en profondeur dans la
connaissance des uns des autres avec un
groupe qui s'étoffe 1 me qui se détruit
pas à chaque fois pour se reconstruire
différemment
donc les projets de voir de voir ça en
tout cas l'année prochaine
merci à vous trois d'être passé sur ce
plateau vous souhaite de bien terminer
la saison et de préparer au mieux la
saison prochaine
on ouvre une page sports américains en
foot us les templiers d'elancourt se
sont imposés assez facilement ce samedi
soir à domicile contre les dragons de
paris score final 28 à 8
un résultat qui permet aux élans
courtois de rester premiers du
classement de la poule b de la deuxième
division casque d'or devant les
pionniers de touraine une équipe qu'ils
affronteront le 14 avril prochain
foot us toujours les templiers
d'elancourt on perdre l'un de leurs
joueurs ans mathis ducrocq que l'on va
voir à l'écran avec ses longs cheveux
joueurs des moins de 19 ans du club
d'intégrer l'équipe canadienne des
électriks football l'équipe qui évolue à
un haut niveau juste avant l'université
pour le moment il restera quelques
semaines au club avant de s'envoler vers
de nouveaux objectifs de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique on continue à parler de
sport us en baseball les cougars de
monde
le bretonneux jouer ce week-end sur le
terrain des boucaniers de la rochelle
lors de la deuxième journée de première
division
bilan mitigé pour les inhumant teint qui
se sont imposés 10 à 2 dans la première
rencontre mais ils se sont inclinés 8 à
3 dans la seconde partie les cougars est
deuxième de la poule b et recevront les
templiers de sénart ce dimanche à partir
de 11h de l'équitation dans ce set 8
sport aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur
un jeune ville provient adrien coller
cet athlète handisport est devenu en
l'espace d'un an l'un des meilleurs
cavaliers de la région grâce à son lien
avec son chevalet zénith en montage de à
eghezée b jana alors mon boulot ça va un
agent vient tous les jeudis adrien
coller un jeune ville provient de 24 ans
handicapée du côté gauche son rang dans
les écuries du château à plaisir pour
monter à cheval
une passion qu'il s'est découverte
depuis un an suite à une première
expérience c'est un ensemble soit on va
dire des valeurs à la proche avec
l'animal en général mais je n'ai pas que
monchal à l'heure actuelle l'animal en
général puis à l'esprit d'équipé qui
peut qu'on peut retrouver dans ce sport
là même si on pourrait croire que c'est
un sport un peu l'individu sa passion
s'est rapidement traduite par des
résultats en compétition adrien est
devenu l'un des meilleurs cavaliers
handisport du département en l'espace de
quelques mois quand la vie tous les
jours est un combat permanent
les sacrifices et les efforts qu'il faut
fournir dans le sport de compétition
et bien finalement pour un individu
comme adrien masset une formalité
des résultats qu'il doit en grande
partie à son cheval zénith l'animal
adopté dès son arrivée au club depuis
les deux compétiteurs sont inséparables
c'est une relation très fusionnelle dès
que s'installe dès qu'ils me voient ils
bailly sort la tête de son box où dès
qu'il entend la voiture arrivait par ace
tourner
il sait que c'est moi qui arrive donc
après l'expliqué réellement je sais pas
c'est vraiment un sentiment aujourd'hui
adrien n'a qu'un seul objectif en tête
avec son entraîneur qui le suit depuis
un an viser les jeux olympiques de 2024
à paris en tant qu'athlète handisport je
m'entraîne pour ça de
de base j'ai dès que je monte à cheval
je me dis allez adrien fait l'effort
dans peu de temps il ya sans doute les
jo qui sont à la porte
en attendant cette grosse échéance de
2024 adrien devra remporter encore
quelques compétitions action cheval
zénith pour rêver à toujours plus haut
et on termine par un rendez vous qu'il
ne faudra pas manquer ce week-end la 25e
édition de la nuit en cours selon rendez
vous est organisé ce dimanche 7 avril à
partir de 9h15
au programme trois courses pour les
enfants et indiqué aux maîtres au départ
du gymnase des droits de l'homme
cette année les organisateurs attendent
près de 500 participants si vous voulez
vous inscrire et reste encore des places
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]